i'm taco cohen and i'm going to present
this uh the third lecture on uh
geometric priors so far you've uh you
you've heard uh michael give you an
overview of geometric deep learning
and john explained the difficulty of
learning in high dimensions and so in
this lecture we're going to start
looking at the kinds of solutions
proposed by geometric deep learning
and specifically we're going to look at
this central concept of symmetry
and we'll introduce some of the
fundamental concepts involved there such
as groups representations
and the notions of invariance and
equivariance
so here's an outline of the lecture
today
so first i will talk about
uh geometric domains signals and fields
of geometric quantities so in geometric
deep learning the data that we're
interested in are signals
so think of things like images
over some geometric domain for example
an image over the image plane but of
course in geometric deep learning we're
interested in much more exotic kinds of
spaces and types of data
and even more generally we're interested
in something called a field
for example a vector field like the
optical flow
image or a diffusion tensor image that
you you might record from a brain scan
so also we'll talk about the kinds of
data that we're going to be processing
and then we'll look at this concept of
symmetry
uh so i'll explain that the general idea
and how symmetry appears in machine
learning in various guises
then we'll look at the particular kinds
of symmetries that we're interested in
in geometric deep learning namely the
symmetries of the domain
we'll study some general mathematical
concepts related to symmetries such as
groups
group actions and linear group actions
also known as group representations
and we'll look at a the specific way in
which the group of symmetries acts on
this space of signals that we defined in
the beginning
uh and then we'll look at the key
concept that should help us
uh uh uh you know learn better models uh
uh which is uh which are these concepts
of invariance and equivariance
all right so let's do a quick recap
of
john's lecture
so
in general learning in high dimensional
high dimensions is intractable
uh the number of samples that you would
need to get a reasonably dense coverage
of your input space will grow
exponentially uh with the the dimension
so if you don't make any further
assumptions uh this is not going to work
even even nowadays with with internet
scale data
if you try to classify images with a
nearest neighbor classifier or some
other naive method
you you wouldn't get very far
um so in geometric deep learning however
that as i said before the data are
signals on some kind of space or domain
so again think of images on a plane
you can have signals on a sphere such as
weather data you can have data living on
a graph
and various other kinds of of domains
and this uh these domains typically are
fairly low dimensional uh and they tend
to come with uh certain uh symmetries
that i'll talk about in in a minute uh
and these uh these things should help us
make learning tractable because we
already know something about the
structure of the data
um yeah so in this lecture i'll i'll
cover this principle of symmetry
and in the next lecture jean will talk
about another
related idea called scale separation
all right so to continue to recap uh as
john explained in in learning there are
or one way to think of it is that there
are three sources of error
you have the approximation error
which means that the true function that
you're trying to approximate say a label
function that assigns a label to every
image in your your data set or every
image in your input space
the the approximation error
relates to
the
discrepancy between the true
label function and the best one that you
can find in your function class so if
your function class is too small for
example only containing linear functions
or only containing containing very
shallow
neural networks or very or neural
networks with few parameters then you'll
have a high approximation error simply
because the the class of functions is
not flexible enough to approximate the
the true function
so this uh this suggests that you want
to choose a very large function class
you want to use uh big neural networks
and indeed of course we've we've seen
over the last few years that that is a
very successful strategy however at
least the classical theory of
generalization tells us that
we can we can then run into an issue
where if we choose a very large function
class
uh we'll also need a lot of data uh so
we get so so
if we have a fixed amount of data as we
increase the size of our function class
or hypothesis class
uh the statistical error will grow
and then finally there's optimization
error which is
related to the fact that even if your
function class has a good uh hypothesis
in it
you might not be able to find it this
will not be
covered very much in the in this course
now
what i'm going to talk about today is
that using geometric prior so these
ideas of symmetry and scale separation
we can decrease the size or complexity
of the hypothesis class for example will
only admit
equivariant neural networks
without discarding useful hypotheses
so this should then improve the
statistical error
because we're reducing the size of the
function class
we're not allowing any more any
non-equivariant neural networks
while not worsening the approximation
error because if we know a priori
that the true
function that we're trying to
approximate let's say the label function
of a function that assigns a label to to
an image
should be invariant to various kinds of
transformation of the image
if we know that a priori then uh
making the hypothesis class smaller by
discarding functions that we know
can't be uh uh
correct anyway should not worsen the
approximation error error
okay
so let's talk about geometric domains so
as i mentioned in geometric deep
learning the data lives on a domain
which we usually indicate by omega so
this domain could be various things but
uh
in in all cases the domain at the most
basic level is a set
um
so and this set usually comes with some
additional structure so you can have
grids for example the
as in the example of planar images each
grid point indicate indicates a pixel
location
and the structure could be a
neighborhood structure so you can say
this pixel is next to another pixel or
you could have a
distance
associated with the the domain as well
saying what is the distance between any
two points in the domain
um you can have
more generally
uh
your domain could be a homogeneous space
we'll talk a little bit about what that
means and there will be a whole lecture
about this later in the course but think
of examples like a sphere or a taurus uh
or some other uh uh
yeah there are other examples as well
um graphs very important very popular
these days uh is another example here
again we have a neighbor structure or a
topological structure that says which
nodes are connected to which other nodes
and finally we have manifolds which to
stick with the 5g theme we labeled
geodesics and gauges
and that's that's that's another example
of a domain
so the key message
of geometric deep learning is that
neural networks for processing geometric
data
should respect the structure
of the domain
so for example if we uh consider the uh
let's say this uh this sphere
uh then there are certain things that
that we consider meaningful structures
such as for example the distance between
two points
um and uh other things that we we don't
consider meaningful and the the neural
network should respect that structure
so we'll get a bit more precise about
what that means in a second
all right so as i said the the uh the
data that we're interested in uh in
geometric deep learning uh is uh
so-called signals on a geometric domain
so what is a signal well it's just a
fancy word for a function
so a signal on omega
is a function we label it by x usually
from omega to
c
where c is some kind of vector space
and the dimensions of the vector space
are usually called
channels
so again the simplest example is a
planar image
as we uh
discussed before the
domain here is set of
grid points the locations of the pixels
and for each pixel uh we then assign a
three-dimensional vector that encodes
the rg red green and blue
values of that pixel and so even though
usually we think of
maybe in in more practical terms we
think of an image
as maybe a vector flat vector or
maybe as a three-dimensional tensor with
width
and height and channel dimensions
we can also mathematically describe it
as a function
and that's what we'll do here because
that that that works
nicely and generalizes
very well
another example would be a graph so here
the domain
would be the set of nodes which will
label by the numbers 1 through n
and then a signal
on this on this graph
could be
the assignment of a
a node feature vector
to each each node for instance uh
telling you for each atom what type of
atom it is for example each gray node
here corresponds to a carbon atom which
would be coded by a one hot vector with
a one in the c channel and then zero
everywhere else
uh so we can we can then consider the
space of all c valued signals on omega
and that's just the set of all f
functions with omega as the domain and c
as the co domain
and that will be
the input space
for our neural network
but also the feature spaces and perhaps
the output space of the neural network
uh will also be of this type so for
example if you have an image
uh you your input space would be
uh signals
with three channels on the plane and
then if you apply a convolution layer
maybe you have now more channels but
it's still going to be some kind of
space of signals on omega
and in the case where you're doing
segmentation of the image signing for
each pixel
for example semantic class then also the
output would be again a signal in other
cases where
you're doing classification then the the
output would be maybe just a single
vector
in any case we denote this space of
signals by x of omega and c and
sometimes when it's clear uh we'll leave
out the omega and c
all right so the first thing to notice
uh about these uh
spaces of signals
is that they come with what's called a
hilbert space structure it's it's just a
fancy word
uh for the the fact that uh it's a
linear space and secondly that we can
can uh
define some kind of inner product which
allows us to compare patterns so if you
have an image you want to for example
compare it to a filter by taking an
inner product so first linearity so what
does linearity mean mathematically uh
just to remind you
uh if we have a signal x
we're going to think of that as a vector
and another signal y we can form a new
signal alpha x plus beta y
and since that's a signal since it's a
function
we can evaluate it at u just like if you
had a finite dimensional
column vector or something you could
index it by the dimension here u plays
that role of index it's a spatial
position that you evaluate this function
at so how is this linear combination of
functions defined
well if we evaluate at u
we
we get um the the value of x at u
times the scalar alpha plus the value of
y at u times uh the scalar beta
and so visually it looks like this we
have here an image x and an image y
and well i i haven't shown what it means
to scale them but if you just add them
then you superpose so for each pixel
you're going to sum the values from the
two images
pixel wise addition
uh all right so that's the conclusion
the the space of signals is a vector
space and that's that's pretty
interesting because the the the the
domain itself omega
need not be a vector space in this case
we took the image plane and in the image
plane there's an operation of addition
and and scalar multiplication defined as
well but if the domain were a graph
uh then we could still do a node wise
addition of features
and so the the the signal space is a
linear space even though in a graph
there's no
notion of adding nodes uh defined
uh if the domain is has an infinite
number of points then the vector space
is infinite dimensional but of course in
practice when we do actual computations
we have to somehow discretize uh to
something finite
and then the second point that really
makes this not just a linear space but
something called the hilbert space
is that we can define an inner product
that we can use to compare patterns
uh and that that inner product is denote
by denoted by these
angular brackets
so the inner product between signal x
and the signal y
is defined in terms of two things first
of all an inner product
on the
feature vectors
so remember our signal assigns to each
point in the domain a vector and for
those vectors let's say rgb vectors
three-dimensional vectors
we we should be able to compute an inner
product well for r3 that's easy just
multiply each of the three numbers and
add them up
the other thing we need is a measure mu
on omega that allows us
to assign some notion of of area to
subsets
of the of the domain and this measure in
in some technical way is used to define
a notion of integration over the
domain
and that then allows us to define this
this inner product so the inner product
of x and y
is the integral of the domain
of the inner product between the feature
vectors at each
position
now if omega is finite dimensional
or if it's a discrete space then you can
use something called the counting
measure which basically turns this
integral into a sum and then
you can see that this really reduces to
the familiar notion of an inner product
where you're sort of summing over all
the points in your domain over all the
dimensions
of your vector essentially and your
summing products of x and y
all right so that's the conclusion the
space of signals is a hilbert space
and i've denoted here in purple some
some some questions that you can look at
uh after the lecture uh to to test your
understanding and you can you can look
up uh online the axioms of an inner
product and then verify that indeed the
thing i've defined here uh uh satisfies
those actions
uh now there's uh so i've said so far
that the data are signals on a domain
but if we want to be really precise then
we have to
generalize a little bit beyond that we
won't be talking much about that in the
in the first few lectures uh only later
when we we talk about manifolds will
this really start to play an important
role
but
in in many cases uh we're interested in
a a
data that forms a field of geometric
quantity so you see here a a mesh for
example and at each point in the master
mesh there's a little vector
that together these vectors form what's
called a vector field
and now the key thing to notice is that
each vector
lives in the tangent space at the at the
point where it uh where it's attached so
the tangent space you can think of that
as the best linear approximation of the
manifold at that point
and although all the tangent spaces at
different points they're so called
isomorphic they're all in this case
two-dimensional vector spaces they are
still different uh vector spaces they
they
yeah they're they're attached to
different points they have different
orientation if you want to visualize it
like that
so to keep things straight you have to
say that uh
instead of saying well i have a signal
or function that maps a point u and
omega to some
feature vector x in a fixed vector space
c
uh when you're talking about fields you
have to be clear that you're mapping
your point u to a vector in the vector
space attached at u that vector space is
often called the fiber at you so for
example this is tangent plane can be
seen as a fiber at the point u here
now again this is uh this is a
technical stuff that that won't be so
important in the beginning but it's good
to be aware of this
right so we will work with function
spaces for now
um
then there are some cases where
the
data
isn't naturally thought of as a signal
on the domain but as the domain itself
so sometimes for example you your data
is a mesh such as this this this picture
of a hand mesh
and that's what you want to process by a
neural network to make some prediction
like what gesture
the person is making
uh and basically the way we we deal with
that is is with a little bit of a hack
by turning the domain into a signal on
the domain so for example if your data
is a graph
then you can
take the adjacency matrix that has a one
whenever two nodes are connected and a
zero otherwise you can view that as a
signal on the domain omega by omega
where omega is the set of nodes
or if you have a mesh or manifold then
there's something called the metric
tensor
that is intrinsic quantity that you can
derive essentially from the the
specification of the mesh or manifold
and that can also be viewed as a a
signal uh specifically a tensor field
on the
on the mesh
so we turn the domain into a signal on
that domain
okay so now let's talk about symmetries
first i'll talk about the general
concept
so what what is asymmetry
so a symmetry of an object is a
transformation of that object that
leaves it unchanged so here we have as
our object a triangle
and what could be a transformation well
we could rotate it and if we rotate it
by
2 pi over 3 a third of a circle
then
the triangle is mapped back onto itself
so that's what happens if you follow
this yellow arrow for example
and so
trees you can flip the triangle for
example along the vertical axis axis and
that's also asymmetry and you can see
that these symmetries already for this
very simple case start to interact in in
quite intricate ways
uh but uh but that's the uh uh that's
that's a general idea
what a symmetry is
um now how is this relevant to machine
learning uh well we'll look at a couple
examples so the first one is symmetries
of the parameterization
so
remember we have our input space x
and we're going to define some layer or
some
whole
network or function
on x that outputs
uh
let's say a label y
now this this function also depends of
course on some weights that will denote
by w
so we have our
for example neural network f that takes
its input some
yeah some data x and some weights w and
outputs a label
then we can have a transformation of the
space of weights
and we can say that transformation g is
a symmetry of the parameterization if
this equation holds if it's true
that
applying the neural network with a
certain input x and some transformed
weights
is the same thing
as uh applying the
network to that same input with the
original weights
so an example
so okay so first of all how does this
relate to the definition well here we
have our
our our function f and essentially you
can think of this function as being
unchanged by this transformation g
applied to the weights
um so an example of such a symmetry
would be swapping all the incoming and
outcoming connections uh of uh of a
hidden neuron so we have here a uh
let's say what's this orange and gray
neuron and we can swap them
along with all the incoming and outgoing
weights
and then if we do a fourth pass here or
four pass here
we get exactly the the same
same result
i
i'm not sure if you see my
pointer i hope it's
visible
laser pointer okay
um
all right so that's that's the symmetry
of the parameterization
now uh this is uh this is a very
interesting example but it will not be
the main topic of geometric deep
learning i just wanted to show it to you
to to
basically make the point uh that
symmetries appear in all sorts of ways
in machine learning
and you can think of other weight space
symmetries for example related to
scaling of weights
then there's the main example we'll
think about throughout this course
that's symmetries of the label function
so we have the label function the the
thing we're trying to approximate
we denote that by l taking input x to
label y
and then we consider a transformation g
now not from the weight space to itself
but from the input space to itself
so for instance we could have
an image and we can apply the
transformation of rotating it
and then we say that this is a symmetry
if the label function applied after this
symmetry is the same as just applying
the label function directly in this case
this is an image of a dog and this is an
image of a rotated dog but we just have
the label dog so the the value here is
the same so then we say that g is a
symmetry of this label function
now
um
it should be clear that if you know
about the symmetries
of your learning problem if you in fact
if you knew all of them
uh then learning would be very easy so
that's shown by this example here we
have a symbolic representation of our
input space x by this venn diagram this
this gray set
here and there are a bunch of points in
there and there they they come into two
classes cats and dogs for for instance
and by the gray arrows
is indicated where a particular kind of
symmetry transformation sends each point
so this point is mapped to another point
and as you can see
all the points are mapped to a point in
the same class which means that this is
indeed a symmetry transformation and now
there are many such symmetry
transformations so you could draw many
other kinds of sets of arrows
that map the points in one class to
other points in the same class
and
indeed any invertible map that respects
the class boundaries is a symmetry of
the label function
now if we knew all of those symmetries
we would only need one label per class
so how do we how do we see that well
if we start at any point in our space
we can apply
all the possible symmetries that we know
about and we would end up
for different symmetries we would get to
different points but they would all be
in the same class and indeed we would
reach all points in the in this class
and so up to a re-labeling
or permutation of the labels uh knowing
all the symmetries is the same as
knowing the labels essentially
uh so what does that tell us well it
tells us first of all that knowing about
symmetries can be very powerful but it
also tells you that
uh it's not realistic to expect that for
non-trivial kinds of learning problems
you you actually would know all of the
symmetries a priori
so
what kinds of symmetries can we expect
to know about
uh and that's uh uh where we get to the
main kind of symmetry that we're
interested in in geometric deep learning
namely symmetries that derive from the
geometric domain on which the data is
defined
so again we have our domain omega
and now we're going to consider symmetry
of this domain so now that's a
transformation not from the data space
to itself but from omega
the space on which the data lives to
itself
so what does it mean for that to be a
symmetry
well symmetry should leave something
invariant
but what that something is depends on
how exactly you define your domain omega
mathematically
so
a general but slightly vague way to say
it is that
this transformation g the symmetry
should preserve the structure
of omega so some examples
if our set if our omega or
whether an element is a member of the
set or not but you cannot say anything
about the distance between uh points or
uh any other kind of relation between
the the elements of the set
so it's a very minimal kind of structure
then any kind of permutation of the
elements
is a structure preserving map
if you have a space where you have some
notion of distance like a plane
then you can consider the
the
group of isometries of distance
preserving maps so in the case of the
plane those would be rotations
translations and reflections
and that
if we define uh omega to to have this
distance structure then those would be
the symmetries
uh you can take the same space this
image plane and you can say well we
don't really think distances are always
meaningful
but we still want to preserve somehow
the smooth structure of this space and
in that case the group of symmetries
would be the group of diffiomorphisms
these arbitrary sort of smooth warpings
of your space
and there are many many other examples
uh that we'll encounter throughout this
course
okay so now we'll study
um
the the the some basic facts and general
facts about symmetries
and the first thing we'll look at is
that symmetries form certain kind of
algebraic structure called a group
so the collection of all symmetries of a
given object is called a symmetry group
so what does that mean well we make a
few observations we first know that
the identity transformation is always a
symmetry right it doesn't change the
object at all so it doesn't change the
structure
um it leaves a structure invariant
uh the other thing the second thing to
note is that given two symmetry
transformations we can compose them
doing one thing
after another
and that will also be a symmetry so if
we rotate and the triangle and then
reflect it
that gives you a rotor reflection that's
also a symmetry
and given any symmetry the inverse of it
is also a symmetry and those are
basically the axioms of a group
so
in mathematics it's studied like this
you you forget about the fact that
your symmetries
uh are transformations you just look at
a set g
the elements of which we'll call group
elements and we think of them as
transformations but they're just for now
the way they're studied is there as
abstract elements and the group comes
with a binary operation that takes two
group elements and produces another one
that we call the composite
and that's denoted by gh
and it has to satisfy these these
properties which reflect the
observations i made on the last slide so
first of all this this uh composition
operation should be associative as is
the composition of transformations
in general there should be some identity
transformation in the group that behaves
like an identity if you do any
transformation followed by identity by
doing nothing that's the same as doing
nothing and then this
transformation g or just doing g
and there should be inverses in the
group so for each symmetry
transformation there should be an
inverse element g inverse that indeed
behaves like an inverse in that if you
compose it with g
on either side you get the identity if i
rotate to the right and then rotate to
the left that's the same as as doing
nothing
now uh the reason
so mathematicians have their reasons for
studying groups in the abstract by for
where they forget about the fact that
the symmetries can be thought of as
functions transforming say
the input of your
neural network
but for us this is also an important
point because
you know let's say we're we're looking
at translation uh symmetry so we have
our our images they can be shifted and
that won't change the label function
well that shift uh that group of of
shift transformations
will act on the input space but it will
also act on the feature spaces and in
general it can do that in in different
ways for example
even quite trivially you might have a
different number of channels so
technically uh the the the group acts in
different ways on these different
feature spaces
um and that can be uh encoded via this
notion of a group action which i'll talk
about in a second so we have to keep
these notions straight we have the
symmetry group
uh that's a group whose elements are
actual functions or transformations
and the group operation then is the
composition of maps we can also study
the abstract group where we forget about
what the g
what the g's are as functions they're
just elements of a set
but we remember how they compose that
you know if i
do a certain transformation followed by
another transformation maybe that's
equal to the identity transformation or
something like that we remember the
compositional structure
and yeah then you can study these groups
and apps abstract and then if you want
to talk again about how the group acts
on data
you need something called a group action
where you take an element of the group
and an element of your domain and you
produce the transformed element of the
domain
and we'll study various kinds of group
actions so for example the group again
the group of translations could act on
two-dimensional points can move a point
in the plane or it can move a whole
signal it can move the the whole image
or it can move a whole stack of feature
maps in your neural network
right so here's a simple example for
euclidean
motion
acting via matrix vector multiplication
so uh what i was explaining here is a
bit of a technical point
that
uh we we have different kinds of
concepts so first we started by saying a
symmetry group
is a set of transformations of functions
g from our domain to the domain let's
say rotating a sphere translating an a
plane etc
and here you have a very concrete
meaning of the of the group elements
they are functions and the composition
of the transformations is just function
composition you can also study groups in
the abstract where you forget about what
the group elements are they're just
elements of a set called the group but
you forget the compositional structure
so you
and sorry you remember the the
compositional structure
so you remember that uh which elements
compose into which other elements and
then if you want to talk about how the
group acts on data you need to introduce
something called a group action which is
a mapping
from the group and the domain to the
domain so let's say a rotation a point
on the sphere and it produces the
rotated point on the sphere
this is useful for us because we'll have
one group
acting on different
types of spaces namely the feature
spaces in our neural network
all right so
if you want to get an intuitive feel for
the structure of a group you can use
these tools called cayley diagrams and
tables
and again i'm using here the simple
example of symmetries of a triangle
this group is generated by rotations and
reflections indicated by the two colors
of arrows that allow you to make any
element in this group
and what you can see read off here is if
you have your triangle you rotate it
by a third of a circle and then you flip
it that's the same as starting here and
flipping and then applying let's say two
two thirds of a circle rotation
various other kinds of relations between
group elements now the same information
can be coded in a table where along both
the
rows and the columns you list all the
group elements so in this case doing
nothing rotation
uh rotate rotating twice there's no
rotating three times because that's
again the identity there's a mirror
reflection mirror rotation mirror and
twice the rotation and then you can look
at each element in the in the table
and you can see what the composition of
these elements is so if you rotate twice
you compose with rotating once you get e
the identity element doing nothing
for example
so uh this allows you to to get a a bit
of a feel for the structure of your
group at least when the group is
finite or an infinite
group of course this becomes
impractical to write on a piece of paper
so there are various kinds of groups
that you can look at there are discrete
groups and continuous groups so uh among
the discrete ones where we have finite
groups such as this example of the
symmetry of a triangle there are
countably infinite groups such as the a
group of translations of the plane of a
line or like a set of points on the line
uh or
of a grid in 2d or higher dimensions and
they're continuous and lead groups like
compact groups like rotations
locally compact groups like translations
and euclidean motions and even non
locally compact groups like
diphthomorphisms the exact meaning of
this is beyond the scope of this this
lecture but
basically
the finite and compact groups and to
some extent locally compact groups are
are mathematically
uh most easy to work with
um then uh
as i um
mentioned these these symmetries
that come from the structure of the
domain they can also act on the space of
signals and that's where things start to
get interesting for geometric deep
learning so if we have an action of a
group g on omega for example we know how
to uh permute the elem the nodes of a
graph then we automatically
get a an action of the same group on the
space of signals on the domain and
that's defined by this equation
we have our signal x and the transformed
signal gx
evaluated at a point u
is given by the original signal x
indexed by the point g inverse u
um and uh i think the next slide should
this slide should make
clear
how that works so here we have uh
here we have our or on the right we have
our
sorry about that we have our original
our original uh signal with the bug here
on the left hand side of the image
and then we apply a translation
so the bug on the left is going to move
to the right
and to know the value
at for example this point here indicated
by the arrow labeled u
to note the g x at u
we look at the original signals signal
at x
u minus t minus the translation so we
take this point u we subtract the
translation and we index the original
image
and that's what we mean by translating
that that's the explanation for why
there's this inverse in the equation
here why we have to index the the image
by minus t
so the key point is
if we have a group action on the domain
we get a group action on the space of
signals
now here's something we can notice about
this particular group action on signals
it's that it's linear so we note that
already that even
does have a linear structure because we
can add signals and
scalar multiply them
but this action i've just defined
because it because it just moves points
around is also a
linear
so
what does that mean well here we have uh
one image x and we have another image uh
y
we can add them then we get this
combined image pixel what defined by
pixel wise edition
now what we can do is we can apply a
transformation g let's say a vertical
translation shifting things down then we
come to this image on the bottom right
and you can note that that's the same
thing as
taking each image x and y translating
them downwards then adding the results
up
and so that is the definition of
linearity so this transformation g is
linear because if you apply it to a
linear combination that's the same as
applying the linear combination to the
transformed uh signals
and that holds in a very general
setup of
signals on a domain that has symmetries
now an a just a name for such a linear
group action is a group representation
so we say this group is represented in
the
vector space by these linear
transformations now if your vector space
if your space of signals is finite
dimensional then a linear transformation
is just
what can be represented by a matrix
so that gives us this
definition
an n dimensional real valued
representation of some group g
is some mapping indicated by row that
takes a group element and produces an n
by n matrix
so it assigns each
of those elements an invertible matrix
that's part of the definition and it
must satisfy this equation which says if
we compose two group elements
and then get the matrix representing it
that's the same as getting the matrices
representing the individual group
elements and then
composing those
so uh this is uh so for example if you
have an uh and
again the two-dimensional image
um we have a translation group or a roto
translation group we know how to apply
those to
uh
two points on the plane
um and then we can also uh get a uh an
action on the space of signals i.e two
dimensional images
and that's linear so we can represent it
as a matrix and that is the matrix
representation
is a matrix representation of the
translation group
so here's another example for
one-dimensional signals with cyclic
shifts and because lack of time i will
not cover this now but i recommend to to
look at the slides and study this a
little bit to make sure you understand
the concept
um another example that's uh
that's very important going to be very
important in this course is the
symmetries of sets and graphs so here
the domain
is a set of nodes or vertices
of
of our graph
and the symmetries are all the possible
ways to permute those those nodes
and then we can study three kinds of
graph features all of them corresponding
to different representations
of this symmetry group group of
permutations the first one is a very
trivial one it's called the scalar
feature so if we have a graph and we
want to assign for example a label to
the the graph as a whole
then clearly we don't want the label to
change if we permute the nodes because
permitting the nodes doesn't change the
graph and so
that can be
you know formalized by saying that the
output should transform as a scalar
feature as a so-called trivial
representation where the matrix that we
assigned to any possible permutation is
just a one by one matrix with a one
in there
i e it's just encoding the idea of
invariance
you can also have a vector feature where
for each node in your graph or set you
have some
number
and
the way permutations act is just by
permuting those numbers as you can see
in this figure and another example could
be where you have a tensor or matrix
feature for example you might have a
number or or a bunch of numbers
associated with each edge
in your
your graph or each pair of nodes
and then to permute such a feature
means to permute both the rows and the
columns of the matrix at the same time
and that's another example of a group
representation
this i'm going to skip as well
uh well the example of grids i think
we've we've covered this extensively uh
so uh
there
yeah you
grids also have symmetries like
translations rotations and flips
and that setup can actually be
generalized to something called
homogeneous spaces so we'll talk about
that in one of the later lectures
so homogeneous space is defined
as a space with a symmetry group such
that
for any two points that you can pick in
this space for example any two points on
the sphere there should exist at least
one symmetry transformation in this case
a rotation that maps one point into the
other
and as soon as you have this uh you you
can well you can understand a lot about
the spit these homogeneous spaces in in
general
and in particular you can you can
develop a whole theory of equivalent
convolutional networks for for
homogeneous spaces so we'll look at how
to develop convolutional networks not
just for the plane but also the plane
with rotation symmetries or sphere
spherical data
and other data as well and you can even
think of the example of sets as a
special case of this as well
then
there are symmetries of manifolds here
we are dealing with something called
gauge transformation which have to do
with the
transformation of the reference frame
at each point
so we'll talk more about this in a later
lecture as well
skip this
right so now we we we get uh to uh
the so we've now studied the notion of
symmetry in general and see how seen how
symmetries uh appear in machine learning
in various ways
um now let's talk about how we can
actually use it
in in geometric deep learning so the
first idea that has been around
basically as long as pattern recognition
and machine learning has been around is
this idea of invariance
so
excuse me
so here the idea is that we have our
input space and we have some uh symmetry
transformations we have for example this
letter a in various fonts and we have a
symmetry rotation that produces various
transformed versions of the of the same
uh letter and we know those have the
same label indicated by the color yellow
here
and so one very natural idea is to just
say well why don't we
find a representation of our data that's
invariant to these symmetry
transformations so if we rotate the
image
our representation denoted by this set
will not change all the rotated versions
of the same letter are mapped to the
same point here
now here as you can see you have less
points this is a smaller space so it
should be easier to do learning there's
less distracting variation going on and
still we can we can perfectly separate
the classes as we could before no no
points from different classes are mapped
to the same representation
so that's a natural idea but that you
run into a problem when you uh consider
this uh for the case of deep learning uh
so
and this relates also to the to the
notion of skill separation that john
will talk about uh next lecture so the
basic observation is that to recognize
whole objects you first need to
recognize parts
and that's basically where neural
networks should be deep right you first
did lower layers detect small edges and
then object parts and then whole object
and
if you make the intermediate
representation the representation of the
parts
if you make that invariant you will lose
critical information as shown in this
this diagram so here we have an original
image of a face uh sideways we can
rotate the whole image but if we just
rotate the individual parts we don't
have a correct face anymore
um and so what this indicates is that
the relative pose of the object parts
contains critical information about uh
what uh what the what the whole uh is
and so you don't want the representation
of the parts to be invariant to
transformations you want to
you know retain the
uh information about the pose and so it
can't be invariant so
what can we do
so the answer that uh that has become
very popular is to use this idea of
equivariance where
you're still
somehow respecting the structure of the
group of the symmetries
but
at the same time you can preserve
a lot of the pose information
so what's the general setup here so we
have as usual in a neural network we
have a number of layers so we have an
input space x0 and a feature space x1 x2
x3 and we have mappings between them the
mappings could be learned layers like a
linear layer or convolution layer a
non-linearity
i don't know a batch normalization can
be anything
and we're just going to think of this
for now as just a sequence of mappings
then what's new is we also have a
symmetry group
uh i've discussed many examples by now
and we have a group representation that
tells us how this group acts on each of
the feature spaces so maybe our input
space is uh our rgb images uh and then
we know how that transforms or maybe
it's a vector field or maybe it's a
diffusion tensor image in 3d or maybe
it's a vector field on the sphere or
whatever depending on what it is we have
a different group and a different way
that the group acts on this data
and then we say that
the layer f1 is equivariant if it's the
case that if we apply the layer
and then apply the transformation g
any transformation from our group
in the feature space that should be the
same as applying it in the input space
and then applying our layer and this
should hold for all of the layers of the
network and as a consequence then the
whole network will also be equivariant
so this is what it looks like for 2d if
you translate the input image and then
you apply a two-dimensional convolution
with this simple edge detection filter
you get the edges also translating so
this is an example of equivariance
uh
usual convolutional networks that just
translate filters
are not equivariant to rotations as you
see in this image rotating input here's
the feature map and if you stabilize it
so you back rotate the feature map you
see that it's changing as the image is
rotating so it's detecting this this
feature map is detecting different
features
depending on how they are oriented
now you can also develop rotation
equivalent networks or what we call
group equivalent convolutional networks
and there
the
the feature map is is truly a rotation
equivalent
and
um
let's see yeah so here's
another way to think about what uh why
equivariance is a is a good idea
basically
so we have uh here on the bottom we have
our input space and again we consider
this problem of let's say simple digit
classification
uh we have the digit a in different
fonts x and y are two uh points in that
input space different fonts for the
letter a
we can transform them produce rotated
versions of that rho 1 g of x rho 1 g
of this should be y sorry about that
um
and then we have our neural network
indicated by these uh
vertical arrows
and let's say that um this network has
learned
to map x and y to the same
point in the feature space indicated
here by a generic letter a that could be
useful because it's just trying to
recognize the type of letter not the
font
so we have f of x equals f of y now if
this network f is equivariant then it
should be the case that taking x
transforming it
and then mapping it to the feature space
should give us the same result as
mapping it to the feature space and then
applying our transformation there
so that already tells us where row 2 of
g should send this point
namely it should send it here but
there's another constraint
equivalence should hold for every
transformation and every point in the
input including y
so if we apply the transformation to y
and then map to latent space we get to
different points so it's not clear where
row 2 should send this
point f of x
uh so if your network is equivariant
this situation will not occur and it
will generalize in a way that's
consistent uh with the symmetry
transformation if these two points are
deemed equivalent mapped to the same
point in feature space then also the
rotated versions of them are to be
deemed equivalent
um
here's a comparison between data
augmentation and equivariant
equivariance
but i again i'm sorry i don't have time
to go over this
but let's look at the summary of the
session today
so symmetries are transformations that
leave an object invariant that's the
general
definition this concept appears in in
many uh
domains
from geometry to physics and we've
looked today at some examples from
machine learning as well
the algebraic structure that captures
all the relevant features of symmetries
are called groups
they have these these properties such as
closure under composition closure under
inverses they have identities and an
associative composition
you can you can study them in the in the
in in the abstract
there are many kinds of groups discrete
continuous etc
now in machine learning we care about
symmetries of the parameterization the
label function and in geometric deep
learning in particular we're interested
in symmetries of the geometric domain on
which the data lives
so the symmetries of the domain they act
linearly on the space of signals on the
domain that's our data or the feature
spaces in our network
and to exploit symmetry and deep
learning we use equivariant networks
we make sure that if we transform the
input
then the output of the network or the
output of the layer will also transform
in the same way
that puts a constraint
on this layer or on the network and
thereby reduces the function class which
should make
learning
easier which should reduce your
statistical error
um and yeah in an equivalent network
each feature space is associated with a
group representation that is a way in
which the group acts
and each layer is equivalent with
respect to these representations
invariance is just a special case of
equivariance
where you use this trivial
representation where every group
elements acts by doing nothing
and that's it for today and i'm happy to
take questions thanks for your attention